when thinking about an ethical problem
first of all you should start always
with your gut intuition
what's my intuition about this case you
never stop there all right you have two
sneaky pushing yourself to say why do I
think this fur thing to do I think is to
think about cases that are somewhat
similar but somewhat different sometimes
it's varying one fact so a great example
from this a classic one and philosophy
is the trolley problem right your are
the conductor of a trolley it's coming
at a branch in the road you could either
you're heading towards five people but
if you flip the switch you can redirect
it so that it kills only one person what
should you do it's a problem well when
we start with that case we then begin
with variations what if it's three
people versus one person what if in fact
there are three tracks and not four and
one of them would lead three perfect
tracks not two and one of them would
lead to your own death for example what
if in fact instead of having to just
flip the switch
we'd have to push a fat man off a bridge
to get in the way of the trolley so
these are all variations in the case and
you begin by thinking does my answer
change by that variation why would my
answer change in that variation can I
derive a principle from this so there
are principles like action versus
inaction the greater versus the fewer
right the question of how proximity I am
did I cause the problem to begin with or
am I just coming on the scene at a time
when I can help for example so you push
yourself to derive principles you then
test those principles out in new cases
that are alike and unalike again that's
one way of approaching the problem the
other is a much more top-down way which
is to start thinking about big schools
of thinking and ethics and really the
big schools are on the one hand
consequentialism of which utilitarianism
is probably the most common which says
that which maximizes good is the right
thing to do
so do that which maximizes good and we
aggregate across people we think of
individuals as containers of utility and
the classic utilitarianism second big
school is deontology of which the most
famous version is probably contain ism
and here there is idea that even if
something would maximize good states of
affairs would produce the most welfare
we sometimes have obligations to do
something different we have constraints
on what we can do and for Kant it was a
question of whether the maxim behind
your action could result in a universal
law of nature that was his test or one
of his tests under the categorical
imperative
so contents think about things like
rights they think can add things like
dignity and they think about it in a way
that's free standing from welfare and
utility and the third big division are
what called virtue ethicists who really
have their roots all the way back to
Aristotle and these folks think that
instead of thinking about the right or
the good instead we ought to think about
character we not to think about what it
is to be a virtuous person one of the
virtues of being a good human being just
as we can say a piece of clothing was
excellently made or horses an excellent
horse they think there are
characteristics of human beings that
make human beings better versus worse
and when we think about what to do we
ask ourselves what would a virtuous
agent do in this situation so that's
another way of approaching the problem a
little bit more abstractly and in the
ideal world those two approaches kind of
meet in the middle and we think about
also other kinds of problems we've
encountered in our lives and what's
helped us in thinking about that so in
the ancient Greeks there's a famous
philosopher who was known for actually
dressing in rags and walking around
ancient Athens he was kind of known as a
crank and a fool and he had like a
lantern and he was struggling always
towards the truth I think that's really
where we are as emphasis we have to
realize that we're struggling through
these conversations we can't avoid
making decisions we're in a position
where we have to decide this is true of
courts also when they're faced with a
particular dispute they have to decide
who gets the kidney do we allow abortion
to go forward are we allowing people to
commit assisted suicide physicians to
assist these are real dilemmas and
somebody has to make a decision but even
though we have to make a decision it's
important to realize we're struggling
towards it we're constantly learning
constantly debating we can think in
abstract terms and think about these
principles and policies and philosophies
which is all very good but it's
important to also realize that we're
situated we are trapped to some extent
by the possibilities of the world we
live in if you look at the history of
reasoning about ethical questions in
particular the example of slavery in
it's easy from where we stand to say
this was a failing of moral imagination
a failing moral ethics these people were
just unethical but in reality I think
the right way to think about it is these
were people who were thinking about
dilemmas in the world in a particular
world in particular eyes world that
doesn't excuse them we can still view
the practice as wrong but we have to
also realize that a hundred years from
now we may be the victims of this
historical kind of judgment right it
could be that our treatment of the
animals for example the idea that we ate
animals is viewed 100 or 500 years from
now as barbaric much the same way we
view slavery or genocide or other kinds
of horrible acts so this is to say we do
the best we can we struggle we have to
be humble about what we can figure out
it's not an excuse for not figuring out
it's no excuse for bringing our best
selves forward but it's also to realize
that in the cold light of historical
judgment even the kinds of decisions
we're able to make will seem at times we
can it seemed at times to the future
wrong I think it's easy to think that
the people who have to worry and think
about ethics are people like me you
study at it professionally or teach it
but in reality every day in your life
you're probably faced with two or three
ethical dilemmas and you may become so
habituated to what you do in the
situation everything from do you give
money to the person begging you on the
street to do tell a white lie to those
of us who are in professions like
medicine or law professional questions
that come up on a day-to-day basis this
is just to say that to be more tuned to
be more in the moment to live kind of a
mindful life there's a kind of ethical
mindfulness that's really good
and you know there's a well-known study
that shows that studying ethics and
thinking about ethics doesn't itself
make you a more ethical person as a
famous study done by psychologists where
people were given a task of studying up
on they were theology students I think
in preparing a sermon on the Good
Samaritan from the Bible the person who
helps other people and they engineered
it so the person was late for whatever
lecture they had to give was running out
and there was somebody with crutches if
I remember the experiment right falling
on the street and the question was with
those people who were given the task of
preparing and thinking about the Good
Samaritan and more ethical and more
likely to help
people who had been given a different
task for thinking about a different
thing and the result was actually no
they weren't particularly more ethical
we weren't less as good as I recalled
the study but they certainly weren't
more ethical than health more which is
just to say studying ethics is great but
living ethics and putting it into little
your life and being ethically mindful is
equally important it's a question of
being aware of the kinds of dilemmas
you're facing in a particular day taking
a moment out of your day to think about
it talk about it with others and think
about how you can live a better life and
be a more ethical person